hello and welcome to this UK shared
Prosperity fund Workshop this is a
shortened version of the one that was
presented on the 18th of April to around
about 20 um stakeholders from from
Rochford
and in this we're going to give you a
brief overview of the uh the program
we're going to talk to you a little bit
about Rochford the funding and the grant
program the timeline so you know what
they are we're going to go in through in
some detail the application form so you
can think about it in terms of your
project and some next steps
I'm Erica Russell I'll be taking you
through the first section of this
presentation and my colleague Celine
Dawson also of Russell and Dawson will
be taking you through the second pod
so very briefly just a little bit of
background on UK SPF funding
um all local authorities have been
allocated this and it's part of the
government's leveling up agenda
the government has created three
investment priorities communities in
place supporting local business people
and skills and sitting underneath each
of these are a range of different
interventions and this is what we'll be
looking at today
to
be given the 1 million pounds worth of
funding which has been allocated to
Rochford they were required to prepare
and submit an investment plan and it's
the basis of that investment plan
um that forms the grant programs you'll
see coming up
there are the program is over three
years uh in year one seventy five
thousand year two which is the one we're
in now the financial year 23 24 around
about 150 000 and as you can see the
program is very much backloaded to year
three uh with just over three quarters
of a million
the interventions that um Rochford have
selected after stakeholder engagement
um are E1 Town centers intervention E4
culture and Heritage and Intervention
e23 which is around business support
and the council have opted to put about
70 percent of year two this year's
allocation
um into grant programs for local
organizations
and they're looking at interventions E1
and E4 so Town centers culture and
Heritage in institutions
the government is very clear that the
competition for projects is the default
position for selecting recipients of
public grants so you will be applying
and there will be a a review process
alongside a scoring process
um to decide who is awarded grants
you can see below the amount of funding
that's available for grants for these
two interventions this year and you can
see that that there is both capital
and revenue and obviously most of that
funding is within the revenue area
UK SPF is a completely new funded
program from government and we would
really strongly suggest you might want
to have a look at the prospectus and
also the outputs and outcomes
definitions something we'll come on to a
little bit later
just to give you a quick idea of the
timeline
um obviously the first workshop on the
18th of April we will be looking for
draft applications to be submitted by
Tuesday the 9th of May and earlier than
that if you have them available and this
is really to support you and to provide
some extra feedback before you put in
your final application
final applications must be submitted by
the 19th of May and uh by noon and then
there will be an independent Grand panel
meeting on the 31st of May to actually
review all of these
and you will find out
um by the 1st of June whether you've
been awarded whether you need to do some
award but with some revisions or if you
and sadly have been rejected and the
funding agreement should be out by the
middle of June
first thing you need to think about is
is UK SPF funding right for you and your
project so your organization and your
project
um you must think about whether you fit
Within These different interventions if
your project is something completely
different
um it just won't pass through the um the
process and the grant panel won't be
able to approve it so think about the
funding for improvements to town Centers
High streets that's E1 and we provide a
few examples here of the sort of things
you might be thinking about
for E4 here you're looking at support
for existing cultural historic and
Heritage institutions and these might be
local natural assets as well as actual
physical building assets as well
so again some examples of areas that you
might want to think about or might might
sort of fit your your project ideas and
these are just examples but they give
you a bit of a feel for what government
is considering
also very important is this idea that
whilst you might have some outputs and
outcomes that you want to deliver very
specifically about the work that you
have in mind
UK SPF funding also requires that you
meet certain government outputs and
outcomes and the council must report
back on these
so what we've shown here on this slide
is the uh for each intervention the
outputs
and the outcomes now you will be asked
to meet at least one output and one
outcome per intervention
and it's important that you understand
what these actually mean to think about
how they could fit into your project and
it may be that actually none of these
are relevant it just doesn't work with
your project in which case um you know
we would strongly suggest you need to
think about is this funding right for
you
again very important to look at the
definitions that the government has
provided
so if you feel that your outputs and
outcomes at least one of these Works
um and you feel that the intervention is
right for you then I would suggest you
then start to think about the project
very importantly you need to apply as an
organization unfortunately government
will not open this up to individuals um
so you might be a registered charity a
registered business you might be an
organization with a constitution and
government's governance documents that
you can provide
um that's fine but you need to be an
organization
you don't have to be based in Rochford
but the project must be delivered in
Rochford itself and government actually
required postcodes for the sites that
are where deliveries are carrying so
this is very important to them
the grant value will be between five and
fifteen thousand for this coming
Financial year 23-24 and you know you
might have a much bigger project or you
might have extra funding that you can
add to a project to make it bigger and
that's absolutely fine
as we said before we'll be offering
support to help with the application
form you'll be getting written feedback
on your draft
um and hopefully that will will help you
with anything you're not too sure about
um and there will be a grand panel um
that reviews the final applications
when you start the application form
we really strongly suggest that you
bring up the guidance document now this
along with all the forms with links to
government information is all available
on the Rochford website on the UK SPF
page the guidance document will take you
through each of the questions and really
pretty much as we're going to do now
we'll give you answers and help on how
you should complete them
the first one is describing your project
now I often leave this one to the last
if I'm actually looking at an
application form because sometimes it's
actually better to sit down and think
about your budget to think about your
Milestones your timeline what you're
going to do and actually once you've got
those in place it can sometimes be
easier to go back and write about your
project
we want to know what you're going to be
doing where it's going to be delivered
who it's aimed at and how you're going
to deliver it so that might be the
volunteers you'll be using it might be
what kind of Staff you'll have available
you need to think about and describe how
it fits with the UK SPF intervention
that you're responding to and also very
importantly you need to make sure that
it actually includes the outputs and
outcomes that will be delivered this is
the UK SPF outputs and outcomes so embed
those into your delivery and explain
when how many
um and just make it clear that you've
you've built that into your project
outline
um
there are local priorities that Rochford
District Council also want to see
supported by UK SPF and they've
helpfully provided in the guidance a
list of all of those that they are Keen
to see supported now I don't think
you'll be able to deliver on all of
those but we'd strongly suggest that you
pick out the ones that are most relevant
and then just respond to those points so
you know investing in stimulating growth
well you might have a particular area
that you're doing so just write down how
that's actually happening
not looking at pages and Pages two or
three paragraphs on most of these
questions is is sufficient project
outline might be a little bit more
the next question is how do you know the
community need or want this project the
grant panel want to understand this when
they're looking at how they score your
project
some people might have statistics some
people might have a lot of data but just
showing that you've talked to the
community and local Partners perhaps
you've surveyed your membership perhaps
you've surveyed visitors it's just
showing how you've thought about those
local needs in the way that you've
shaped your project
so practical answers but this is an
important question
also
um Rochford and the government as you
are fully aware are committed to
equality and diversity and you need to
show how your project will also support
equality and diversity
so think about it in terms of your your
own organization how that actually works
through into the project and it could be
how you're going to communicate both and
perhaps how you are thinking about the
people you want to engage with but also
how you communicate equality and
diversity to those you are working with
we also want to know how your project is
going to operate sustainably so this is
around the environment climate change
reducing carbon emissions
so perhaps out learning how you do that
within your own organization could be
helpful in how you're going to build
that into the project that you're going
to run might be about thinking about
travel to venues travel to sites car
sharing it could be about the building
that you operate but also about how you
engage with the community as well on
this issue we've seen some creative
projects who've actually Incorporated
climate change into some of their
creative activities
quite a tough one
um question seven is about project
Legacy and here we're really trying to
get a feel for if this project is
delivered in Rochford what kind of
long-term impact Can it have can the
project continue
um can it be continued through the work
of volunteers that you've set up and and
supported is it something more fixed
that is going to be available for a long
period of time so very useful to be able
to think about that it's a hard question
and
um moving on to the sort of more project
and program side of it um delivering
risks delivering or sorry delivering
orders has risks some of these I'm sure
that you're quite comfortable with you
may do this work quite regularly it
might be
um incorporating DBS checks this kind of
thing
so as well as the risks that you uh can
kind of see with your normal everyday
work around these projects
the panel will also want to see that
you've understood that there could be
risks with this funding stream as well
so we know that you have to collect
evidence to demonstrate that you've met
outputs and outcomes you have to keep
financial information to show that you
have
um spent the money in the way that you
have that your procurement has worked so
we would also suggest you think about
these kind of risks you may have match
funding risks you may also have risks
around administrative time and expertise
so think about the project as a whole
rather than perhaps just the actual
um main delivery Focus
we talked about outputs and outcomes as
part of the application form you will
need to put down the number and then how
you're going to collect and evidence the
data here whether it's for E1 or E4
think about this in sort of quite
practical terms but please please refer
back to the outputs and outcomes
definitions because it does give you
some guidance on what government is
expecting and all of these have to be
reported back by RDC to government in
their reporting as well
so here we have the outputs and outcomes
for E1 remember a minimum of one output
one outcome
and for E4
um exactly the same format and again one
output one outcome minimum but if you
can do more that's excellent
in terms of administration you will need
to provide a report on Project progress
including your outputs and outcomes
every three months and at the end of the
project
you need to make sure that you've got
the time and expertise to do that and
it's very helpful to explain how you're
going to manage this and this isn't just
Financial you will need to keep records
of perhaps events that you've run you
might decide that you need
um to have photographs of those you
might have people might sign up for it
and you need to download that
information so it's not just Financial
but obviously finance will pay a part in
this as well perhaps put in the name or
the role of somebody who'll be
responsible for this that can also be
very useful
Milestones
um Milestones timeline
um this will be available on a separate
spreadsheet this isn't on the word
document that you'll download for the
main application and it's the first tab
here we want you to think about what's
going to be delivered when and it could
be that you actually need quite a bit of
work to set up a project so that might
take up several lines you might be doing
different things over the first three or
four months
um it could be that you have a series of
events should show when those happen and
if you can
um try and show where your outputs and
outcomes will also occur so that it
helps when you're thinking again about
your project delivery and your budget do
these all tie together
and now I will hand over to Selen um to
talk about budget
so here on question 12
um you need to indicate your budget
between each intervention but Earth
Source split between capital and revenue
funding you can it is possible that you
answer may be a zero on e4 if you're
only working on E1 and vice versa so
it's not a problem you can even choose
to work on two interventions or just one
in order to fill in this question on the
word document you will need to First
fill in the excess spreadsheet
so the excess spreadsheet is comprised
of the timeline as you can see Eric has
just talked about it but also there are
three additional tabs around the budget
the budget summary tab which we are
looking at will give you the answers to
question 12 and this is where your
budget is divided between quarters and
intervention and then as well between
interventions and revenue and capital
funding
this tab doesn't need to be filled in
it's automatically calculated thanks to
the formulas
but in order to get v-stop filled in you
will need to fill in either a budget for
E1 or budget for E4 or buff tabs
depending on what your project is
so this is an example of what you will
see on your Excel spreadsheet so you can
see here we've got budget for E1
the column A please select budget line
by using the drop down list
this is you click on the drop down list
and this is where you're going to choose
what budget line you will be working on
I'm going to go through each budget
lines
just to indicate
you know what usually what cost usually
would be under which budget line so the
first one is Staff cost and this is the
time spent on the project by your
employees when we say employee these are
people that you've got a a contract of
employment with and that receive
payslips from your organization
uh stuff travel cost is related to those
people that are your employees and that
need to claim their costs relating to
for instance going to a specific um
venue for an event or for a meeting and
here you will include either mileage or
maybe they've taken a bus or train so
you need to include this costume there
applicate applicant time if not an
employee so this is for instance
yourself
um you're working you've got you're part
of an organization you may be the the
director of this organization you often
you are not an employee because um this
is not all you work with organization
you may be a sole Trader usually you're
self-employed and here is where you can
include your time to deliver the project
for instance as part of your project you
will deliver workshops this is where you
indicate uh your time
the budget lines to play out of goods um
this is this is for costs such as we put
example here of craft supplies banners
chairs any Goods that you may need to
deliver your project and you that you
will be purchasing for the project it
could be
um as simple as
um you know buying some refreshments as
well
um directly
um supply of services
um again this is
um a service provided on to your project
for from an external provider or
contractor
uh it could be that you request a
marketing agency or a marketing
specialist to do social media for you or
design some marketing
um tools it could be that you've got
artists where you want to work on a
project someone to deliver a workshop uh
it could be a tournament organizer or an
event organizer
um anyone that is not employed by your
organization and you need
um to pay them for their services
volunteer is expensive
um so this is for volunteers that work
on your project and you would like to
reinforce their costs for travel and
subistance
um so this is where you can budget for
this cost
small equipment
um we've indicated here could be laptop
printer mobile phone tablet any
pieces of equipment that are cost less
than five thousand pounds and are
absolutely required to deliver your
project
all of these budget lines I've just
mentioned are Revenue costs
um the last one which is called Capital
cost
um this is the budget line for for
instance refurbished refurbishment work
so it could be that you would like to
reboot refurbish a room in
um
in a in a venue in a in a building
um and it's an asset and that is going
to make a difference for for the years
to come
um it could be equipment which cost over
five thousand pounds so some of the
equipment it could be for instance a big
3D printer that costs more than five
thousand pounds this will be a capital
cost not on Revenue cost
um
once you've selected your budget lines
in your drop down list you will also
link to fill in column B which is for
each budget line and each item of
expenditure you need to describe what
the item is the expenditure is for uh so
for instance for stuff you will use a
line payment per member of staff and you
will include their job title uh their
role in the project the number of hours
they are going to work on the project
um if you're looking to
um have a supply of services services
and then your indicator for instance uh
doing marketing created a lot creating a
logo anything that you would like to
describe for the service you're going to
require
it's important that you indicate as much
details as you can
um so that the chrome chrome panel can
understand your project what
expenditures but also we will be able to
provide advice if we feel that maybe
it's indicated in a wrong budget line
once you've described the expenditure
you will then indicate how much the cost
in each of the quarters
um on the right hand side and please
make sure that it's linked to your
timeline and it fits with you within
your project delivery activities
once budget for E1 and all budget for E4
is filled in you will then go back to
your budget summary this will be
automatically updating as you fill in
your project and your budget sorry and
then you'll be able then to go back to
question 12 on the word application and
fill in the
um the the the answers
question 13. this is about the match
funding
so this question is is not scored and
this is just for indication and really
to understand your project understand
the risk link to them and here you can
see that you will indicate
um whether the money the match running
is available already so now I know so
much fundings for instance if your
project costs 20 000 pound you're
actually asking for 15
000 of UK SPF funding
um we don't need to know the details of
the five thousand pound but we would
like to know if the funding is secured
already if you're planning on applying
uh to another funders for this 5000
pound and
um if maybe you if you've got a plan
really
um so if you select the amount on the
right hand side of the table you
indicate the amount and then add the
additional comments you just let us know
a little bit more about where the money
is coming from and whether it's secured
or not and from
foreign
question 14 is again it's not a scored a
question but it's an important one
because here we want to make sure that
um they are as the least risks at as
possible in terms of procurement
so procurring external goods and
services has got rules according to the
UK SPF funding these are the UK public
sector procurement rules and it's very
important that you thought of them
because these will be attached to the
funding and therefore applicable to
yourself
um here you can see director wrote for
any cost under 2004 for 2499 I just need
to have one quote and then there are
different rules for 2500 to 24 999 and
this is where you need to show that
you've requested free quotes from
different suppliers
and then possibly less something less
applicable to you but please keep an eye
on it is anything above 25 000 pound
will need to undertake a tender which
has got more restrictions it's important
that you look at the um at the guidance
and look at the rules and then make sure
that in question 14 you answer about
what you think will be applicable to
yourself and for what type of cost so
that we we make sure that this is
understood and they are the least
responsible
how to manage your vat so you will
confirm whether you're vat registered or
not
um if you are that registered you will
need to exclude any vet from your budget
and your claims if you get approved
because ukspf will not pay recoverable
vat
if you're not but registered then feel
free to include all cost and including
v80
um
because this will be an an acceptable
cost Keith uh you're not bad registered
then feel free to include all cost and
including v80
next steps um so as we said earlier
um everything will be available from the
20th of April
um that includes the application form
the guidance the information document
budget spreadsheet timeline spreadsheet
um and and this short video
um there will also be an FAQ sheet that
will be updated with your questions any
any queries you can email the ukspf at
rochford.gov.uk email address or you can
call the following number
key dates uh 9th of May is when is when
we would like to really have received
your um Draft application by
um you will then get your feedback uh
and we would like the final submission
to be done by the 19th of May
following this there will be a process
of scoring and a grand panel we will
look at all of the application form and
discuss the the the programs that should
be um
approved or not uh you will be notified
of the outcome for your application on
the 1st of June and we are hoping that
all projects will be ready to start by
the 1st of July
thank you very much